this video plans to compare the story of
the original Resident Evil to its
recently released remake counterpart
I'll be going through the Remake story
and pointing out what the Remake changed
regarding the story and whether or not
these changes were better than the
original then at the end we'll come
together and see which one Reigns
Supreme either the Original Classic from
2005 or the revisioned remake of 2023.
this is of course a story analysis so
spoiler warning for the re4 Remake going
forward as I will not be holding back
once we begin I would also say spoiler
warning for the original re4 and the re2
Remake since we will be referencing some
of those games events but the remake of
the fourth game is the most important
one since I don't expect you to play
three games just to watch this video
with that out of the way though let's
get started so the first thing we see
before we even start the game is a recap
of what happened in Raccoon City already
we can see that the tone of the game is
much different than the original the
Remake goes into detail as to why this
day is so significant for Leon and how
it changed him permanently it references
all the deaths that Leon saw that day
like the lieutenant Ada and kendo's
daughter his last line in this section
is this time things will be different
which is quite important for the story
going forward the original doesn't even
touch upon these details at all it just
summarizes what umbrella did and what
happened after Raccoon City and that's
it I personally like the remake's
decision to add more drama to the
narrative as it was severely lacking in
the original as such though quirky
one-liners are not going to be a common
occurrence in the game given its more
serious tone Leon in the original was
cocky he knew he was the best and knew
that Salazar and Sadler weren't going to
beat him so it's no wonder his ego is
through the roof throughout the game in
the remake though Leon isn't as cocky so
a lot of his famous one-liners are gone
from this entry for example his no
thanks bro when first meeting Salazar
and the I've got gum line when
responding to luis's question if Leon
had any smokes are not present in this
game he'll also doesn't even tell
hunnigan that he got tied up in some
things after literally being tied up
just moments ago while I do miss some of
the lines especially luis's when he
calls Mendes The Big Cheese it doesn't
really fit with the tone of the game in
fact adding it to the Remake would Clash
too much with the current story and
cause a conflict of emotions as Leon
would go from having a heart to heart
with Ashley to making fun of Salazar for
being old in just a matter of minutes
and tonally that doesn't make sense that
doesn't mean all the one-liners are gone
or that Leon doesn't say any new ones of
his own but the original definitely has
a lot more this change is like some of
the ones we'll talk about today it's not
a subtraction or addition of content
it's a complete change so it's hard to
say whether the remake or original is
objectively better in this regard since
Leon feels like two different people at
times so it's less about which one is
better more about which one you prefer
personally while I do miss the overly
sassy Leon of the original I think I
prefer the remakes take on him instead
given how the story will play out in the
chapters to come soon after this is
where we get introduced to a lot of the
gameplay systems and get through the
iconic Village opener one thing I will
give to the Remake is that it manages to
keep that feel the original had despite
most play players already knowing what
to expect anyone who's played the
original knows about the village Ambush
and likely knows the proper routes to
take while the Remake does change things
quite a bit it's still largely the same
yet despite that the Ambush felt as
fresh and scary as it was the first time
through this not only goes for the
village but for the gameplay in general
oftentimes the game's story and gameplay
are intertwined with one another this is
especially true for Resident Evil as the
whole premise of the gameplay is to feel
scared tense and nervous and not just
the jumping out of your seat when a
ganado grabs you kind of scared more so
will I have enough ammo to make it
through this fight kind of scared
running out of ammo midfighter really at
any point is almost certain death and
not knowing what comes next coupled with
the fact that you know you won't have
enough supplies to take on the encounter
anyway gives off this very scary feeling
and I felt that both in the original and
the Remake it always felt like I was one
bad encounter away from losing a large
chunk of my Supply so I was on high
alert at all times even though re4 is
more action horror than survival horror
the Remake felt the exact same as the
original when it comes to build ups and
scares I fought Mendez Salazar the
Verdugo and all the others before but
the remain still had me on the edge of
my seat during each fight which is
extremely impressive towards the end of
the chapter is where we get to meet
everyone's favorite Spaniard Louis Sarah
if there was one major complaint I had
about the original it's that pretty much
every character was underutilized with
the exception of Leon and Luis was at
the top of my list his performance on
screen in the original was almost
laughably bad at certain points as usual
he ends up locked up somewhere and is
forced to stay there until Leon saves
him he then immediately leaves after
they escape comes back for an ambush
Mission then leaves again only to return
claiming that he has the sample of the
lost plagus they were looking for only
to somehow drop it on the way there and
then after all that he dies the moment
he finds it all of it is just bizarre
thankfully the Remake gives him a bit
more screen time and a much more boring
role in the overall story Luis in the
original was a researcher who used to
work for umbrella before the whole
Raccoon City thing occurred but now he's
working with Sadler to test the effects
of the Lost plagus parasite eventually
though he started to catch on to
Sadler's real intentions with the
parasite and felt immense guilt over
what he had done which is why he
betrayed him and allies himself with
Leon and Ada in the story though he
pretty much does nothing which is a real
shame as he had the potential to really
stand out as a prominent side character
in the Resident Evil series his remake
version is far superior though as not
only does he not die at his usual spot
in the timeline which gives him more
screen time but anytime he does appear
he always does his best to take Center
Stage Luis takes the time to explain the
Lost plague as parasite and what it's
doing to Ashley and Leon as well as talk
about his past and the experiments he
did under Sadler most of this
information was delegated to text files
found throughout the game which isn't
bad by any means but hearing from the
horse's mouth is a lot more impactful it
also characterizes Luis more as these
talks he had with Leon made him really
stand out in the remake sadly Louise
still dies but his death felt like it
had more meaning to it Louise was
someone who recognized the error of his
ways and tried to atone for what he did
by doing the right thing and while he
wasn't able to see it all the way
through he still thinks about Leon and
Ashley in his final moments as he gives
them a key to his lab which is where
they get the parasite taken out Leon
also offers to light his last Sig which
just shows how much of an impact he had
on him it's also the first time Leon
will meet krauser and one can
immediately see that he's gone off the
deep end already Louise felt like a
genuine person and while it does suck
that he didn't get to see the credits in
the remake his character had developed
far beyond what his original form was
capable of he was our main source of
knowledge on the lost plagus and he
played his role perfectly the same
cannot be said for Ada though Ada is
still my least favorite character in
this whole game her presence in this
game is kinda pointless even though her
actions here set up the events of
Resident Evil 5. once again just like
Luis her lore is more intriguing than
her story Ada is obviously a spy of some
sort who works for a secret company that
we don't know about at the time she's
here to take the Lost plaga sample back
to her organization which mirrors a lot
of her actions in Resident Evil 2. she
was always trying to find ways to use
Leon said she could further her own
agenda and she continues to do the same
here and the story though Ada's main
claim to fame is infamously arriving on
scene saying a sense or two at best and
then refusing to elaborate on what's
going on here my absolute favorite and I
mean this sarcastically is later when
Leon meets krauser Ada breaks up the
fight the two boys are having and then
literally leaves a second later before
Leon could get a word in she does this
at least three times throughout the
story and it's incredibly annoying to
have to sit it because you know it is
just going to stall us and not further
the plot I know this has kind of become
her thing at this point but just because
it's what she's known for doesn't mean
it's a good thing in the remake Ada is
the same way and Capcom sadly didn't
take the opportunity to delegate some
time in the script for her on the topic
of her while not a criticism of her she
is present here so I figured I should
mention this but I was kind of
disappointed in her reveal mostly
because of what re2 had potentially set
up in both re2 and re2 remake Ada
supposedly dies only to give Leon a
rocket launcher to use against the final
boss in the original though you get the
sense that Leon knew it was her since he
calls out to her during the fight in the
remake Leon has no clue where the rocket
launcher even came from I figured this
was going to affect reform since the
Leon's knowledge Ada is dead but when
the two meet there's barely any emotion
coming from him almost like he knew she
was alive the whole time Leon and her
did leave off on a very important
discussion which was then Leon
confronted her about not being the FBI
agent she claimed to be but I feel like
Leon should have been a bit more
surprised about this interaction hell
Ada herself says huh you don't seem
surprised interesting it is entirely
possible though that just like his
original version Leon in between games
found out about ADA and her work which
is why he's not surprised that she's
alive regardless probably the worst
crime Capcom committed when making Ada
was not including her Side Story
separate ways I don't know if Capcom
plans to add it later as DLC but I find
that even more jarring than if they
didn't separate ways was a sub story
that allowed you to play as Ada for a
few chapters and while it's an alright
piece of content at least to me it's
strange that this wasn't in the remake
it's not like the original and is only
unlocked after beating the game it's not
integrated into the story by giving Ada
her own chapter it's not even extra paid
content it's just non-existent and
that's incredibly disappointing not just
because it was already in the original
but it continues to hurt Ada as a
character as now she's even less
interesting than she already was in re4
thanks to a piece of content revolving
around her being missing from the
official release at the very least
though thanks to her we got to see
Wesker in the re engine so Silver Lining
our final character at least when it
comes to good or morally questionable
individuals is Ashley and I wanted to
save the best for last because Ashley is
fantastic in in the remake Ashley and
Leon were part of a very typical Trope
relating to the Damsel in Distress
Ashley went a bit too far with that
Trope for my taste as she is utterly
useless at just about every point in the
game I don't mind the idea too much and
admittedly I found the dynamic to work
well at times but actually from the
Remake showed me what I was missing she
herself has not only changed but lots of
small details were taken into
consideration when designing her Ashley
is still very much a damsel in distress
kind of character but she shows genuine
growth throughout the Remake which makes
her feel like once again an actual
person instead of just hiding and
forcingly on to do all the Dirty Work
Ashley goes out of her way to help Leon
as best she can during the Ambush with
Luis both he and Leon finish off the
gennados and then discuss what next
steps to take in the remake despite
being told to hide she eventually leaves
and instructs the boys to follow her to
safety she also and this was a lifesaver
throws these blue lanterns down at the
infected armor so you have an easier
time killing them I really like the
direction they took Ashley in this game
as she showed that she genuinely cares
about Leon and will go to Great Lengths
in order to help him which is where her
Mission comes in Ashley's playthrough
was quite short and not incredibly
interesting as all she really does is
just find her way to Leon by taking an
alternate route using a key she found
but in the remake Leon ends up getting
trapped by Salazar and Ashley has to go
find a way to release the lock this
takes her through some pretty terrifying
areas as it changes from an action
horror game to one of those more
standard horror games like Outlast where
anything you do to the enemies is just
meant to slow them down since you're too
weak to actually kill anything the game
also fully utilizes the new stealth
mechanics of the Remake which I found to
be quite useful in certain situations
such as this Ashley in the beginning was
very much the Ashley we remember and the
game hammers this home as she could be
seen covering her ears once the fighting
starts so she's not used to loud noise
over time though she starts to feel more
confident in herself she's still not
capable of doing much on her own but
she's taking a lot more initiative this
time such as when she willingly gets
into the bulldozer so she can create an
opening for them to walk through she
didn't do this because Leon told her to
she did it because she knew she could
and also wants to show Leon that the two
can work well as a team in fact this
Dynamic these two have is probably my
favorite part about the whole remake
Ashley leaves care for Leon and Leon's
motive to not let what happened Raccoon
City happened again created this
incredible Dynamic that seized these two
constantly looking out for one another
in times of Crisis and also check in
once in a while after a fight Leon might
ask Ashley if she's doing okay to which
she'll usually respond that she's doing
fine it's incredibly minor but it shows
that Leon does care about Ashley's
well-being and Caesar is more than just
a job he wants to make sure she's safe
not because it's his duty to protect her
but because he cares about her the two
aren't just all doom and gloom though as
the game gives them ample time to joke
around and build their relationship like
when Ashley is shocked to see Leon swing
from a chandelier or when she channels
her inner Jill Valentine
pretty much a master of Milwaukee like
any relationship though it's inevitably
going to go through some rough patches
anari Force case about 90 of it is a
rough patch seeing as Ashley keeps
getting kidnapped and the two are
separated for hours at a time but the
one I'm actually more focused on is when
Ashley turns on Leon as we know Leon and
Ashley were infected with the Lost
plagas parasite and Sadler's able to
control those that are infected by it
which is why he was able to force Ashley
to stab Leon this scars her if she
doesn't want to be nearly on anymore not
because she's scared of him but because
she's scared of hurting him at this
point in the game though Leon's gone
through much worse hell you've probably
died a few times already so a cut to the
hand isn't going to kill him not by a
long shot but still this is a terrifying
moment for Ashley as she was just forced
to hurt the one person who's trying to
save her and she doesn't want to kill
Leon while being under Sadler's control
this ends up coming back around much
later toward the final few moments of
the game where instead of Ashley just
blindly walking towards Sadler and away
from Leon she is instead forced to shoot
Leon but somehow manages to keep him
alive thanks to her resisting his
control but mostly because the bag was
empty thanks to her firing off a few
shots now I don't think anyone who
played the original thought Leon would
actually die here but still it's quite
intense and a lot better than actually
just walking away from him like before
their relationship really hits a peak
right at the end when the two are
moments away from turning and you can
see the desperation in Leon's eyes as he
tries to make sure Ashley lives even if
it comes to the cost of his life just
like their relationship I'm glad that
the infection itself got a lot more
attention this time around as it's the
main motivator within the story if the
characters don't get this out of their
bodies they're screwed so all their
actions hinge on getting this parasite
out of them and I'm glad that there was
multiple times throughout the story that
the game focused on our Duo feeling the
parasite getting stronger as the game
went on to be fair the original did this
on occasion too like when Leon almost
choked out Ada but the Remake definitely
doubles down on this story beat overall
most of our main cast has vastly
improved since their appearances in
2005. Leon has a different yet
interesting personality he's a lot less
cocky but isn't afraid to throw out the
occasional one-liner when he wants and
having the remake of four focus on his
mindset and actions during the events of
two was a very smart choice as it keeps
the Remake games in line with the Remake
Canon and overall makes Leona more
complex character Ashley and Louise
showed incredible Improvement by being
more active throughout the script being
able to do certain battles alongside
Luis battles in which he wasn't
originally in thanks to him dying were
incredible and it was great to see him
be more than just comedic relief
actually going from a damsel in distress
to a more confident woman was a nice
character Arc for her seeing her
demeanor change over the course of the
game thanks to Leon were some of my
favorite moments in the story and the
relationship the two have now was the
highlight of the game Ada is okay I do
wish we got to see more of her
throughout the game even if she doesn't
explain things like she usually does
because I think implementing a chapter
about her could have gone a long way and
could have given us more insight into
her whereabouts throughout the game
still though 3 out of four ain't bad at
all
these were the biggest changes of note
in the Resident Evil 4 remake but just
like our last episode on the Dead Space
remake there are a lot of smaller
changes that were also present that I
couldn't fit cohesively into the script
for starters I really liked krauser in
this game as opposed to the original
Crosby's first appearance in the Army
Universe was Resident Evil 4 so no one
knew who he was and why Leon knows him
it was very hard to care about his
situation with his past battles when I
barely had time to meet the guy the
Remake introduced his crowser a bit
earlier than before and also has him be
the one who kills Luis providing the
player and Leon a reason to remember him
the game also lays out some documents
regarding the day that impacted krauser
the most which is when his entire unit
was killed by the us as he claims since
the Army refused to extract them out of
their Zone this led to all of them dying
with Rouser which has immensely affected
him his mind is still very much stuck in
that battle and seeing him act like it
was a war during this boss fight was
really cool I've always liked the layout
of the Boss Arena but the Remake adds to
it by throwing in a few new sections to
ramp up the intensity plus the game's
updated knife mechanics which include
durability and parrying make the fight
more cinematic honestly a lot of the
boss fights in climactic moments are
throughout the game have this sort of
cinematic feel to them like the Dual El
Gigante fight with Luis in the original
it was just a fight but in the remake
it's made more cinematic by adding
different things to the fight like Louis
strapping Dynamite to its back there's
also the minecart sequence that was a
lot more cinematic than before and
filled with a lot more action and
thrills than the original had similar to
Leon's personality I think this one is
more personal preference if you like
being able to do the fight and just
figure out where to go from there then
the original will satisfy that but if
you like the bombastic railroaded
sequences where things are played out in
a set order of operations and the Remake
is more your style the one boss fight
though that is bound to catch some
debate is the removal of the u3 fight
before krauser personally I don't mind
this not only is the whole fight just
weird as we're fighting on a very
specific set of floating shipping
containers in the middle of a cave but
u3 was literally thrown into the plot at
like the 11th hour so if I'm being
honest I'm kind of glad it's not the
Remake on the topic of bosses Salazar
and Sadler are just as good as before
and it was also nice to see Sadler use
more mind control during the game I also
really liked how there were text files
on the guys that would eventually become
the Verdu go in the El Gigante we fight
I don't remember if these files were in
the original but either way it's a nice
attempt at humanizing the beans we face
and reminding the player that just about
everything we're killing in this game
even the more deformed looking creatures
were all human The Last Detail that I
noticed and I was very much a fan of was
the constant Showcase of plot relevant
details I talked about this just a
moment ago when we discussed Louise but
the Remake likes to show a lot more of
the plot to the player this time around
rather than just keep it all in text
files we end up finding a very huge high
with a call dug out the Amber that held
the parasite and even finds an equally
large piece of Amber sitting in a
storage room in the original these
details were an afterthought as all we
knew is that the call dug up the
parasite that had been buried by
Salazar's ancestors and then they got to
work experimenting on it the Remake does
its best to point out these areas to the
player whenever it can which I
appreciated as a final note I think you
can tell given the contents of the video
but yes the Remake is far superior to
the original in regards to its story if
I'm being honest I've never been a huge
fan of Resident Evil 4's story Resident
Evil 4 on release was way ahead of its
time and revolutionized the gaming
industry but while its gameplay was
incredible I felt that the story was
lacking in a lot of ways the Remake does
its best to shave away the problems but
it's hard to do that without completely
changing the entire structure it does at
least make the story more palatable
which is quite impressive given the plot
it's working with Resident Evil 4 though
may not have an amazing story but it has
a lot of charm Leon's personality is
infectious and carried the entire game
for me changing Leon's personality had
me worried about the quality of the
story but I was more invested in the
relationship going on between Ashley and
Leon that I could care less that his
original personality was reshaped to a
more serious attitude and Luis and
Ashley taking a more active role in the
plot rather than letting Leon handle
everything was a great decision as it
characterizes them more than just the
damsel who always needs Leon's help and
a Spaniard who dropped the plot relevant
item halfway through the story
but these were just my thoughts on the
game let me know what you thought about
the Remake in the comments down below
either way thank you for watching the
video today like And subscribe if you're
new for more story analysis like this
pick up the Dead Space video for another
remake comparison or any other video on
the channel for a more in-depth critique
of a game's story with that out of the
way though thank you to my returning
viewers for coming back to another video
and take care everyone goodbye